all right moving on saturday is world
autism day and rocky hung out at the
accelerated learning academy today to
see how they're helping our local
families affected by autism
i am still holding and cherishing my
bouquet here this place has completely
made my week so dr gwen you get to do
this every day what does it mean to you
it means a lot it's a long time coming
we wanted to build an environment that
we could invite both neurodiverse and
neurotypical kids to come together to be
educated and to be able to grow and you
guys have been here since 2013 giving
the community these services but only in
this new facility since november so what
does this facility bring to the
community and how does it enhance your
programs in this facility we built out
specific classrooms so kids can get a
true school experience like they would
in any other school building wow okay
and as you can see this is we're in the
pre-k classroom now the energy here is
so fun and inviting and all the kids are
having so much fun and they're smiling
jelly you're a teacher here so i have to
ask you you know what's the learning
environment like
it's fun it's very inclusive and i'm in
a kid a piggyback ride right now so yes
fun is definitely the answer yes we are
we're fine we're pretty inclusive and we
always value our learners achievements
and
yeah we celebrate the little things and
they give you a workout you're out of
breath girl
and people for people at home who you
know might have an autistic kid in their
family you know what are some of the
ways they can start learn teaching them
at home
really encourage a lot of independents
encourage
communication making sure that we are
encouraging a lot of learning at home
like little things
describing things identifying things
expressing their emotions yes and i
remember dr gwen was telling me um you
also want to just enhance you know and
focus on what what you discover they
already like to do right like if they
like to draw then make them draw a
little bit more yes
again encourage their
forte
make sure we are building those
hobbies if our
kids love to draw maybe maybe they will
be a picasso one day i love that i love
that speaking of special children let's
go over here to my little buddy
he's cooking in the kitchen right now
hey what do you love most about your
school tell everybody what you love most
about your school
[Music]
yeah that that was the face of
excitement you can find out more
information of accelerated learning
academy on their facebook page so just
type that in and you're good to go thank
you dr gwyn for having us thank you i'll
send it back to you
i loved that story thank you so much
rocky we'll be right